I was defending like this guy through like a couple of the claims.
Oh my god.
Somebody told me a guy got crazy at the end. If you look at the
absolute files, it's clear that we are run by secret
>> One more thing. Let's let's do let's do the interview.
All right. We get we're going to watch Professor Zang. Professor
Zang's insane. The real power, the real
in the world is not money. It is human consciousness or basically
attention. Okay? This is This is it, guys. Okay? When you understand
this idea, you understand everything.
This war is being fought to control
the consciousness
of the human race because it is our consciousness that creates
reality itself. That's the source of all wealth and all power
in this world.
Okay? That's why this is happening. In other words,
this is a war not just for Iran. This is a war not just for the
Middle East. It is a war for the soul
of humanity.
This is what's happening, guys.
All right? This is what World World War III is. World War III
is meant to be the last and final war of all human history
because whoever wins this war will control the very soul of human
existence
for all eternity. Okay? That is the end
I watched a Fantesy clip where he was talking about how Professor
Zang was basically running the Khazarian
like conspiracy theory. Like the Khazaria that that that's where
Ashkenazi people originate from. Like that whole conspiracy theory.
He was running that.
>> I believe something along those lines. And it's like,
dude, what are you? Yeah, so we'll see. See what Professor Zang
has to say. >> Heavy hitter guest and first-time guest
on the show. >> Havana Sungenis.
Uh he'd be a big believer. But listen, I waited until I was 30
years >> your faith at all in it?
No, cuz I am I am totally grounded in my belief in Havana syndrome.
I just don't know what causes it. Professor Zhang He is the star
of the predictive history. He uses game theory to analyze past,
current, and to predict uh future geopolitical events, and he
joins us now. Professor, great to have you. Good to see you,
sir. Thanks for inviting me. Yeah, of course. So We brought this
astrologist on to do foreign policy analysis. Good to see you,
sir. He almost saluted I swear to God I saw Sager going to salute.
He was going to go so Thank you for coming on, sir. Professor
Zhang, sir. Thank you. Thank you for being here. What a nerd.
So, um you know, for people who aren't familiar with your work,
I wanted to show folks that back in uh 2024,
you made three big predictions. One, that Trump would win. Two,
that he would start a war with Iran. No one saw that coming.
Three, that the US
would lose that war. Let's take a listen to that. In a two-candidate
race, you picked the right candidate.
I didn't realize that he said the US would lose the war.
Maybe Hold on. If he if he predicted some of this stuff, maybe
this would be more impressive if the video I saw of him here,
and him to predicting like what Iran would do, if he predicts
like Iran hitting all of the Gulf states at the same time in
in this video from 2024, that is more impressive.
I don't necessarily respect the process, but that is more impressive
if he's doing that. >> class this semester, I'm making
three big predictions, right? First is that Trump will win
uh in November.
Second is that
Okay, also, I don't know if he's actually a professor. He graduated
with distinction from Yale College in 1999 with a degree in English
literature. Dude, there's no way >> But he's English lit
PhD, but he teaches
Not an English lit PhD.
An English lit undergrad. Oh. I do not believe he has anything
beyond that or it would probably say so. There's no way he's
really got no higher education than this, right? It's not on
his Wiki page, but I feel like he's got to have something higher
than just an English lit degree. that United States will lose
this war, which will forever change
the global order. So, obviously that last one is uh the only
one who is that is not yet come to fruition is quite a stunning
prediction. You know, do you stand by it and what have you seen
so far that leads you to sort of stand firm in that conclusion?
So, um given my analysis of how the war's progressing,
>> think that Iran had
I I think he does a video where he explains where they're why
they're going to lose and I don't think it's from back then.
I do believe he predicts like an
We'll see what he gets to, but yeah, it is deeply unserious.
You'll see which ones that I say like this is a crazy claim.
You'll I won't even have to point it out to you. You'll probably
naturally stop at the points where I'm like, how could you just
say this and there's no pushback from either of them to be like,
do you care to clarify or substantiate that further? I mean,
just let it I mean, there's a reason why this video has 5 million
views and probably a largely positive comment section is because
she just let him talk. >> I know, in 2 days. >> 5
million views? What? That's
That's insane. >> It's actually kind of genius for them
to bring him on.
I mean, it doesn't look quite so genius if they just sit there
while he says totally insane things, but No, that's also genius
because you will like they're trying to get his audience and
if you don't really push back that much, it's like, oh, finally
some sense out of independent media.
You know.
Uh I think this guy's got some crazy crypto opinions, too. We'll
see. >> over the But, I might look into him more after
this. Time to snark on Professor >> United States. Um the
reality is
>> He is. It's a war of attrition between United States
and Iran. And the Iranians have been preparing 20 years for this
conflict. In their eschatology, in their religion, this is a
war against the Great Satan. They've had many um practice runs.
Last
>> 12-day They've been preparing for this war via their
religion? Like this is already like a mode of analysis that I
would be like, what? Like when people try to analyze these conflicts
as a function of religiosity,
immediate immediate red flag.
Uh I think I don't hate the idea of what he's saying here that
he's like
I don't hate what he's saying. That like >> It's to be
it's it's the it's literally the equivalent of being like, "Did
you know the Hamas charter says they hate Jews?" Like going like
starting from that point, I'm like, "Yeah, I know that it says
that, you know." I know they're like a a theocracy.
I feel like saying the Hamas charter includes like hating and
then the the Great Satan stuff, like that's not really comparable.
Like I don't know if Hamas starts every you know, like I I understand
some of this is propaganda, but I truly believe like in that
regime, every part of that regime is built towards like resisting
uh American and Israeli influence and like fighting the decadent
West. Like I think I think there is something >> But you
think that that's primarily a function of their religion? Well,
it's a way they've incorporate I mean, they've literally changed
the religion in order to facilitate that, right?
Oh, if they have done that, then I didn't know that.
Yeah, so they literally I believe
Khamenei is the person who introduced the idea of martyrdom.
Before that, it was like only in battle could you fall and enter
heaven. So, Khamenei like switched that all up and yeah, so it's
I like I I don't think I disagree with this that much. I actually
kind of do agree with it. war, when Iranians were able to examine,
analyze
the strike capacities of both Israelis and
And they've had a lot of time, 8 months, to prepare fully for
um this new attack. They through their proxies, the Houthis,
Hezbollah, Hamas, and the Shia
have been able to um really grasp the American mentality
and now they have a pretty good strategy of how to weaken and
ultimately destroy the American empire. Mhm. So, what the Iranians
Okay, so at least Saagar looks concerned. At least Saagar is
like, wait, what? At least, right? Facially, he's like, huh?
Wait, wait, what? >> that's kind of just Saagar's face,
to be
Is it? I don't know. Dude, we're they're in a prime position
to destroy the American empire, guys. >> Houthis, Hezbollah,
Hamas, and the Shia militias have been able to really grasp the
American mentality
and now they have a pretty good strategy of how to weaken and
ultimately destroy the American empire. Mhm. So, what the Iranians
are doing is they're not they're waging war against the entire
global economy.
And so, they are striking >> Like that.
Like Iran's waging war against the entire global economy. Like,
how?
Or like, how do you mean?
striking critical energy infrastructure all around the region
and causing energy prices to spike by striking >> think
that like making something as economically costly
for the United States is the same as saying that you're trying
to like declare war against the global economy.
Yeah, they're literally trying to declare war against the global
economy and doing so very effectively right now. That's not a
crazy statement at all. They're literally causing a global energy
crisis like single-handedly right
Um one of the biggest gas one of the biggest liquid natural gas
stations in the Middle East had to shut down and will take weeks
to restart in Qatar. >> It's one of those things that like
everything you're saying I I will agree with you, but I still
wouldn't I guess I just wouldn't like categorize it as like,
"Oh, you're declaring war against like the world economy." But
yeah, it's good it's like having these side effects, sure. But
But it is literally I do not believe that they think they're
causing any damage whatsoever to the Gulf States. Those Gulf
States are totally like they've got trillions of dollars, right?
Between them. They They They're not going to sweat from this
at all. The places that are going to sweat are anywhere that's
downstream that needs that energy to survive. There are energy
stockpiles in a whole bunch of Western countries. I think Russia's
got a oil stockpile like sorry, Australia's got an an oil stockpile
that'll last 30 days. They get all of their oil out of the Strait
of If the Strait of Hormuz is not open and with ships flowing
through it, which is why Trump says, "I'm going to escort people
out." Like there is real pressure there. Like he is actually
scared of this, right? That's why Trump is saying, "We'll escort
oil tankers out of the Strait of Hormuz. We'll make sure they're
not hit by anything."
This is a real
actual thing. >> But like Trump is not scared of
That's not speaking to his bravery or anything like that, but
No, I mean like he understands that if if price like and as energy
costs increase, global shipping costs increase, every product
in the world's price increases. Like this is going to have cascading
effects. He does not want cascading inflation globally for the
next like 3 months that's going to be blamed on him. That I'm
I'm not joking. This is not crazy. This is like I think almost
No, it's just dramatic to to categorize it that
And not further elaborate, but like maybe he did or whatever
at this moment. >> Sure. That those grand claims, I get
it. But like I And I also just like think it I I know what he's
saying. He's saying like in retaliation they're doing this, but
the framing is also weird because it's like
they're not they're doing this in response to a war of choice
that was declared by Israel and the United States. Wait. Sorry,
say that say that again.
They're They would not be engaged in these actions were it not
for the United States and Israel undertaking the military decisions
that they did. So, when he says when they it's framed as like
so like even if he does caveat of like in response they're declaring
this or whatever, it's just weird because
they really don't have the uh
Well, it's it's literally their military
Like they >> their strategy right now, the only way they
get things to go away right now, the only way they get any relief
from the attacks they're facing is if they make this war totally
untenable for the United States. That's the only way they can
get away with um like not having not getting bombed out of existence
repeatedly over and over again for a long time. And so, they
are trying to cause energy prices to spike and then they're going
to just try to hide and and weather things and hope that the
pressure they're putting on economically causes opinion against
the war to to shift against them so they can
have some hope. I I don't know. That's that's like That's their
strategy explicitly right now. What they're hoping for. So, I
I think that's I I do think it's in reaction and I do think they're
they're basically saying, "Okay, well, cuz the global economy
to them would be just the American Like they they think that's
all run by America anyway, right? They're literally going to
shut down like a whole bunch of like as much as they can and
make things as costly as they can and turn it into a war of attrition.
That I think they have like because of the restrictions on the
on America, I think they have like some sort of chance like there's
a hope down that path for them. Uh it's going to be awful for
the rest of us. It's also something that the US when when they
talk about the orders that were handed out, and the US knew who
was getting hit and what was getting hit, this would have been
a part of those orders that they knew about, by the way. Mhm.
Absolutely. They would have had some idea that this was a wrong
strategy, and they went anyway.
Guys, were you doing well economically before this? Well enough
that you would totally sanction like more more of a recession?
Everybody, you feeling good economically? You feeling like you
got all of your needs taken care of? >> reaction just going
to be you agreeing with the professor?
Um on this one thing. I mean, I don't think that means Iran wins
the war. I do think that that's their strategy. I think Trump
is obnoxious enough and can't be elected again and is probably
dying in such a way that it doesn't really matter. So, to him.
Like, the rest of us living with a recession or living with our
lives totally fine. Right? The rest of us living that way Not
a huge fan of Trump.
Yeah. the GCC countries. And not only only are they striking
GCC countries, American bases, they're going after the critical
energy infrastructure of these bases. They blocked off the critical
moves. And eventually,
um they will go after the water desalination plants, which is
the lifeblood of these nations
Okay, I don't think that part that part is where it starts to
get away from me. They've struck the oil infrastructure.
He's saying they're going to struck the strike the desalination
plants. I think the desalination plants would be counterproductive.
I think that would be horrible strategy. So, he's talking about
this whole game theory. He I don't think they want to kill a
whole bunch of people in the region. They could they could send
a ton of drones out. They could launch drones constantly and
totally crash them into civilian areas in these cities, like
in these densely populated um Arab cities. They could cause a
a ton of damage. I don't think that's their goal. I think this
is crazy. Um they don't want death. They don't want destruction.
They want like economic damage. A damage that hurts the United
States, damages Israel, and the reputations globally. I think
that's what they're looking for. Cuz if they don't have fresh
water supply. In fact, uh the water desalination plants provides
60%
of the um GCC's water supply. If they wiped out a desalination
plant in Riyadh, uh Saudi Arabia, and it's a city of 10 million
people, right? Um, they'd be out of water in 2 weeks.
Um, in 2 weeks. And right now, the Iranians have de facto closed
off the Strait of Hormuz, and the GCC gets 90% of its food from
uh the Strait of Hormuz. Like it's not clear again like why he
thinks that that would be the next target. Cuz like you're saying
that would like if assuming nothing no one intervenes, like mass
death or what like make it incredibly difficult because I guess
the United States would step in and give water to this to them,
but like
I wonder why he thinks that naturally follows. I mean, it could
cause a massive humanitarian crisis in the region, possibly.
But I Like I yeah, it doesn't make sense to me. It's like um
It It doesn't make Yeah, it doesn't make any sense to me. I It
could put pressure on. But I don't Again, I don't think they
want to
to like do these all of these things to people in the region.
I I think that's a step too far for them, to be honest. Maybe
I mean, maybe Saudi or something,
There's also a water crisis right now. Because it's a maximum
damage strategy. He's a game theory guy.
I guess so.
The force Oh, McBoots, I understand that. I understand why
Oh, I'm going to say wrong, Josh Kosh.
Sorry, somebody's saying it's supposed to UA UAE, Saudi Arabia,
and Dubai to use their wealthy wealth to pressure the US. I understand
why they're doing it with energy. I'm saying as soon as you start
doing it with um as soon as you start doing it with water and
like significantly with these countries, I don't know where the
next place to get water from, but they'll open the Strait of
Hormuz to prevent that kind of crisis. And
I think that's like all gloves are off. Like literally, hey,
US, like here's a ton of money to build whatever you want and
bring whatever you want over here. We'll literally fund this
entire operation.
[__] Iran. Like like there's a level of, you know,
there's some games gamesmanship going on where yeah, Saudi, they
all they all dislike Iran, but they're not fans of Israel, they're
not fans of America. But if you do that
suddenly they're fans of Israel and America. Suddenly it's Iran
like to death into the dirt. Like
nothing left. So I I don't think they want to risk that personally.
I think that's too much. Anyway, we keep listening to this guy.
I think I do think it's goofy to go after the desalination plants
and he can't I I guess somebody explains it in chat. It's the
maximum
damage strategy, but it just doesn't make sense to me.
Yeah. the disruptions to global economy.
But right now the Iranians are actually threatening
the very existence of Saudi
Um, you I will I will say though
I don't think Saudi or any of those other countries can contribute
anything militarily. I'm pretty sure they're like totally like
their their personnel are worthless. They're like they're they're
not trained, they're not effective. Um, I mean, Saudi the Saudis
are impressive like when they want to be in the context of this
specific
conflict, I don't know that they're going to be of much assistance
When are they impressive? When they're bombing like
like Houthi fishing boats? I was going to say it's probably half
people in Yemen.
Yeah, they they literally like they they're so ineffective
that they can barely hit like the the huts in Yemen, okay? uh,
Qatar.
And what is important is that uh, the Gulf states are really
the linchpin of the um, American economy. So what they do is
they sell petrodollars and then recycle the petrodollars back
into the American economy through the investments in the stock
market. And right now we know that the entire global entire American
economy is propped up by AI investments in data centers. A lot
of that comes from the Gulf states. So if um the Gulf states
are no longer able to sell oil
and they're no longer able to finance
AI this AI bubble in the United States. So this is I think this
is a particularly like categorically
opinion on his part. We're going to take No no no no no. Like
this could all be true by the way. This I don't I'm not even
saying that the petrodollar isn't funded like local investment
in the US or something like that. I'm sure the Saudis have their
hands all over I'm sure the UAE has their fingerprints all over
it. It doesn't matter. He's basically arguing that they don't
also have just
like warehouses full of pallets of US dollars that they could
just immediately invest if they wanted to. Like what you're talking
about is not the the shutdown of the Middle East. You're talking
about a couple a couple days maybe a couple weeks of energy crisis
and the Saudis can just weather that. Whatever they do for spending
they could just weather that. The the Emirates could weather
that. The Qataris could weather that. It's it's like the rest
of the world and their supply of oil that will get with. Everything
with America will be fine. It's it's the rest of the world cascading
effects, okay? It's one of those things where when you see mass
inflation you see like
fairly large, you know, famine events in the third world in the
global south broadly. Stuff like that. Like there'll be cascading
events but it won't be stuff that hits the US or pressures the
in that exact sense.
I don't think it'll topple the the American economy. I think
it's going to put us into a recession but that's I think that's
as far as it goes. Then this AI AI bubble bubble will burst and
with it will will
will burst as well as well the entire American economy which
is really a financial party scheme. So that's that's a dire situation
that Americans are facing right now. Yeah, I mean to your point
sir an Amazon data center was literally hit in the UAE. And now,
of course, big tech companies were
Did Sagar listen to a single thing this guy said? Uh actually
>> He's just waiting for him to stop talking so he can
try to impress him with his little factoids that he wants to
see if this guy will incorporate into his analysis on the spot.
What What does that have to do with anything this guy just said?
Hey, they're trying to foment a global energy crisis they're
going to cascade into like a a global food crisis and investment
like a bursting the AI bubble in the US and he's like, "Well,
they hit a data
Why does it That is like
>> has nothing to do with it. It's like there's a data
center and I think AI goes in a data center. Okay, He's talking
about capital investment in the United States, okay? Jesus Christ.
which we're looking at the UAE as a major potential data center
investment hub with cheap and abundant energy, probably going
to be re- rethinking that. We also want to talk to He's talking
about capital INVESTMENT IN THE UNITED STATES.
SORRY. about munitions. Uh we can put this next one up here on
the screen. United States is racing to accomplish Iran mission
before munitions run out. This is specifically around interceptor
math. There's a famous video just from yesterday in Israel, which
shows a single Iranian ballistic missile which is being targeted
by some 11 different interceptors, all of which miss. Most of
those come from the United States, not to mention all of the
different bases the GCC countries that you just talked about
and the the asymmetry of the cost. It's a million-dollar per
missile, tens of millions per interceptor in some of these I
guess about 3 million for the interceptors. I think for the uh
what is it? The Patriot missile systems, about 3 million per
interceptor. >> cases with But the the issue is you have
to fire multiple interceptors at each >> munitions running
out. How does that change the global picture? So, you're a Um
but the
Sure. Oh, this is a good question. I thought he was going to
Some people say that like Iran's going to keep firing missiles
and the US going to everybody's going to run out of interceptors
and Iran will have free reign, but Iran's running out of um like
missile launch platforms as well. They're They're losing their
capacity to launch missiles as well. >> China, obviously,
much of the stocks in Asia of the United States are likely to
have to be cannibalized if this were to go on. How's that going
to affect the global picture here? Right. So, uh my first point
is that the United States military is not designed to fight a
21st century war. Remember that the military industrial complex
came to being after World War II and was designed to fight the
Cold War. And the Cold War was really about muscle flexing, about
about who was able to send uh people up in the space, was able
to who was the first get the person on the moon, who had the
more uh complex
um missile systems. And so, the entire American military strategy
revolves around very uh sophisticated sophisticated technology
that cost a lot of money to uh build, and that's
I It's weird.
I literally Does he think aliens exist? >> It's just weird
to me that like this,
me like this
Iran can win, but the United States will lose. Wait, what did
you Did you mean Like this is all like this like every single
point that he makes is being
in favor of the conclusion that this is why Iran will win.
Yeah, I mean he means winning in the same way that the Syrians
beat the US in the '80s, right? Like literally we're bombing
you and and it's literally not worth it for you to be here. Like
you're literally like it's actually just hurting your image being
here and and losing like one soldier even though we send a whole
wave of people. Like it it sucks for I think that's what he's
talking about. It's like a total caustic victory, Pyrrhic victory,
rather. Mhm. I think I think that's what he means, but like and
like I kind of get it. Like Iran can't win in a military sense.
Also, I don't know what this point is in favor of. The US is
Yeah, I don't know what he means by 21st century war. Like I
I could kind of drive with the idea that you could make it too
expensive for the US to stay there. Like it's just a bad investment
to stay there. But yeah, this I don't know what he means by win
to be honest. He it it sounds like he I I agree with you cuz
it sounds like he's saying that Iran will like rise. They're
the mighty lion and they'll rise and like defeat the US >> God,
and it's like this is that's just like typically
I mean, I don't know. Maybe I don't disagree with him that much
in that sense. Like the same way that you know, we had these
forever wars of Afghanistan.
You know, like can we say that we won them? Same with Vietnam.
it's hard to think of it in terms like that even though that
might be the historical retrospective because it's going to cause
there there are going to be so many consequences in the short
term for Iran that to say like they're winning is weird, you
know.
Yeah, it's a it's Like oh yeah, Iran definitely got the better
of the United States in this.
It's like you just hit somebody so hard. It would be like the
the Kissinger stuff where they're like carbon copy >> won?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's like it's basically like that. Like technically
you had to win without you had to leave without getting your
objectives, but you like your country is totally obliterated.
That's like the kind of win they're getting, right? Like we prevented
the US from gaining their objective, which is regime change.
But also we have no >> Cuba Cuba won maybe. I think maybe
Cuba is probably the closest analog that you could say. Yeah,
something along these lines. And it's like they have no hope
to ever reintegrate with the global economy and all of like there's
just it's the everything's bad. It's all bad. >> It's what
the um American air defense system is is basically and that's
why we're seeing this asymmetry as you point out in in this war
where you have these million dollar missiles trying to take out
these fifty thousand dollar drones. And it's not sustainable
uh in the long term. And so what we're seeing is really the puncturing
of the aura of invincibility and invulnerability that sustained
American hegemony for the past 20 years, especially after the
collapse of the Soviet Union. And this is really a reordering
of not just a global economy
because this signals the collapse of the petrodollar and with
it the entire
US dollar base reserve currency system. >> Also pause.
But also um Like what's the time scale for this cuz when he's
like it's not sustainable, it's like dude we spent $300 million
a day for 20 years
to try to prove a point. Like it can be sustained like that that
is 20 years of sustained military effort even if it all collapses
at the end of it. Yeah, I
If I if I had to be nice like if I'm trying to think best of
what he means or try to give him the best interpretation, he
probably means not sustainable in terms of public opinion versus
cost and benefit. >> has never cared about that.
Yeah, it's one of those things where he's basically like in a
that's the issue with game theory is it assumes rational actors,
right? That's probably the biggest issue with what he's trying
to do is he's not a rational actor. >> I I would be more
open to this but because it's Trump and it's he just picks up
things and puts them down one week to the next like we heard
about the Greenland annexation and we stopped hearing about the
Greenland annexation or like acquisition,
we'll bail out Argentina and then move on from that, we depose
the head of state for Venezuela and then that's over with, we'll
strike Iran's nuclear facilities and then that's done until we
get back involved. Like there's no coherence to this other than
[snorts] just like doing it cuz he can and because there's people
in his ears and like the TV that he watches like Fox and Friends
of like egging him on to do it. Yeah, I've got a couple theories
from chat as well. Like I I do think it's not coherent but in
terms of what this guy might mean, people are saying um just
in terms of the missiles versus the interceptors, I do think
that's a point, but I think people are really over
People are underestimating
how degraded Iran's capacity to launch their high-grade weapons
are. If they've been keeping their best ballistic missiles in
tow trying to wait, I do believe they've like narrowed down the
amount of launch platforms they have and vehicles and all of
this. Unless they've got like a bunch of secret missile silos
somewhere that the US and the Mossad could not figure out or
could not find out about, which to me seems kind of
But unless that's the case, like that would be a bad strategy
cuz they're not going to have any launch platforms to fire them
from. Right? So people people think this and maybe it's a way
it it sounds to me like Bernie Sanders math, but maybe I can't
I can't rule it out. At least it's more believable than the Yeah,
you know, Bernie can still win. He can still win the primary
in 2016. >> that. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, it's like the Bernie
math. It's like people are kind of coping.
They hit Yazd? Oh, they did hit Yazd now. Okay. So they've hit
like their big their big stockpile facilities that they hadn't
been hitting before. I I believe Iran's still got stockpiles
of missiles and stuff, but um but I think that's the platforms
that they're running out of and they're not going to be able
to launch from a bunch of places. Anyway, so those could be other
theories. I think
America's showing why they needed to continue and I don't know
if they have, but they needed to massively ramp up domestic production
of all ordinance and stuff because it's obvious the world is
moving to a place where we're actually going to have to go into
combat like the American army will actually have to work and
do things and the low rate at which they're building ordinance
and stuff was not even remotely close to what was required to
continue to play the same role in the world that they were planning
to or that they had been
Or not or just not. Um I don't know. You You do risk if you don't
have the production capacity, you risk falling in into a place
with China where like one
suddenly leaves you with no army like no way to rebuild your
losses and suddenly a far less technologically advanced army
rules you over.
So, I don't know. I think I think they do need to keep I I think
they need to spiral up a lot more construction of all these ordinances
and stuff.
See. Cuz this signals the collapse of the petrodollar and with
it um the >> Oh, also everything about the petro These
are like insane
like
to believe what he's saying or to I like to to believe that there's
credibility to this, like the fact that the global market's working
at all basically tells you that this is unlikely to be the case.
Like the fact that the stock market is still running, we haven't
hit Armageddon. If this was like at all likely, if this was all
at all a possibility really that anybody
uh you'd see things really starting to shake and they aren't
anywhere near enough. entire
US dollar base uh reserve currency system, but also um global
uh the global hegemony of the United States. We're moving towards
a multipolar world. Professor, this morning Secretary of War
Pete Hegseth uh was asked a question about potential ground troops
um in Iran. He refused to rule out that possibility and he said,
you know, oh well, we're not going to project to you what we
will or will not do. What we don't want to, you know, rule anything
out. We will do what it takes. But they always take this posture
on anything though. He said that Vance said this on
in a position to the right of Biden where he was saying that
like way to the right, way more interventionist by saying that
uh like that wasn't off the table if necessary to end the conflict.
>> anything off the table. Yeah, I think It's It's that.
It's like not ever really like curtailed or specific to any
any any one conflict. I think it's just a go-to line.
Yeah, I think it pulls really well with the MAGA base as well
that they're like, yeah, never take Never take anything off the
table. You got to negotiate. It's the art of the >> we
have to do.
Yes. We'll end up um invading Iran from the ground since it's
already becoming relatively clear they won't be able to accomplish
the goal of regime change or even regime collapse using just
air power alone. Right. So, everyone says that the worst calamity
that could happen in the United States is if it were to send
ground troops into Iran. The same time
the United United States are committed to regime change in Iraq.
We never had
uh an president in history where you were able to regime change
from the air alone. You need ground troops. And so, unfortunately,
what's going to happen over next few months is that uh pressure
>> track record with that. So, I'm feeling we may not even
attempt it.
Uh yeah. Well, I think this is, you know, from the very beginning.
If you were on the Listen, you don't pay attention to this stuff.
If on the first day you weren't saying Syria 2.0, you don't pay
attention, okay? It's Syria
They want that entire country totally destabilized. That's the
goal. Been the goal from the beginning. Not from the US, but
from the you know, from the
the real president, the shadow president, okay? It's been the
goal. It's just
>> is that
I'm talking about Israel, by the way. Not a Not a conspiracy.
Israel's very
Israel's very transparent that this has been their goal for a
long time. Uh pressure will build on America to send ground troops,
especially from the GCC countries and from Israel, which are
being pounded right now by uh the Iranians. So, remember that
if the GCC countries, Saudi Arabia,
uh Qatar, UAE, Bahrain, if they go, then the petrodollar goes
goes with them. So, the Americans need to protect these countries,
and these countries are going to demand
that um either the uh Americans bribe the Iranians to cease.
And this This is like $520 in indemnity, okay? Mhm. Or send ground
troops to wipe out the Iranian threat once and for all. And I
know that there's no political will for ground troops uh to be
used against Iran among the American people, but remember that
78% American people was against initial strikes against Iran
in the first place. Right. And one of the things that really
comes into question, I think, with all of this, sir, when we're
looking at the geopolitical Sure. picture and the sacrificing
and much of this uh from the United States on behalf of Israel
is kind of a question as to who and what wanted this. We were
actually curious for your view on a disputed report here from
the Washington Post. We can put it up here on the screen uh F3,
a push from the Saudis, Israel helped move Trump to attack Iran.
Now, this has been internally disputed by Saudi Arabia saying
that they did not push the Trump administration to attack Iran.
However, this is clearly an authorized leak or a government trying
to at least
I just
I I I must be given second
I literally just would have believed this like if there was no
report published, I would have just believed this, right? Like
it's I'm sorry. I It's not Nobody thinks there's love lost between
the Saudis and the
And there's no there's no like ethnic There's no ethnic solidarity
there. There's no um religious solidarity there. In fact, there's
religious antipathy there. Like of course they Of course they
wanted Trump and and Israel to go and do it. place some of the
blame on behalf of the GCC. What do you make of this analysis
and of of this narrative that Saudi Arabia was also trying to
be behind this push to bomb Iran? So, I always argue that both
Saudi Arabia and Israel are heavily invested in regime change
in Iran. In fact, Saudi Arabia sees Iran as much more of an existential
cri- crisis than Israel. Because remember, Israel still has nuclear
weapons and Israel is a very diverse, very sophisticated economy,
whereas Saudi Arabia is completely reliant on oil. And it's always
had problems with Iran because Iran is a
What's that?
The this idea like go go back to what he his comments were specifically
on the Saudi Arabia relations with Iran. You see, what do you
make of this analysis and of of this narrative that Saudi Arabia
was also trying to be behind this push to bomb Iran? So, I've
always argued that both Saudi Arabia and Israel are heavily invested
in regime change in Iran. In fact, Saudi Arabia sees Iran as
much more of an existential threat >> they normalized relations
in 2023
with Iran.
And then they later came to they were like opposed to the JCPOA,
but then they later came to accept it as okay.
Like this idea that Saudis have like always been looking to like
regime change or whatever. No, and you I don't think you can
point to the uh to the attack on Saudi oil facilities like in
2019 to argue this either.
I think I think they've always disliked Iran and the Iranian
regime, but I don't think they've like I think the Saudis seem
pretty capable of like hating people and doing business with
them and have been for as long as I've been following this stuff.
Like right, like they seem like >> whole like
insistence that like no, they want regime change.
I mean, they want Trump they want to make money with Trump. So,
if Trump wants regime change and you're arguing that they are
committed to it because he's committed to it, but it's not clear
that he's committed to it necessarily,
then I guess by that view they're committed to it. But he the
way that he's framing it suggests that it's like no matter what
they what like despite you know, things that have happened in
the very recent past with respect to the relations between these
two countries, ignore that in favor of this convenient narrative
of like they've always wanted
Yeah, I feel like they don't like I I do feel like they did support
Iran getting struck by Israel and and but I just think they love
when another another power is degraded in the region when the
when the focus is on somebody else. Like I I do think they generally
don't like them, but they're not going to like go to war with
them. They're not seeking to change that regime. I'm not sure
they really believed regime change was possible in Iran, to be
honest with you.
Like I I I don't think they would have thought it was possible
cuz I don't think they ever thought that US boots on the ground
were possible in Iran. I'm guessing like most people they would
have just thought like there's no way that's ever happening.
So, I'm not sure they would have really entertained it, to be
honest.
But it sounds like once they heard that it was going to happen,
I I would believe that they're like behind it, to be honest.
Well, I don't know. At least a couple people in my chat who don't
think that the Saudis would be agreeing to it. I There's two
schools of thought. It's the the Sunni-Shia thing causes them
to hate Iran enough that they will support the strike or that
the balance of power, like upsetting the balance of power in
the region would not be good for them. That I think a lot of
these Gulf states do just think like Israel's got a list and
they're going through it slowly, like meticulously, and they
think they'll be on it somewhere eventually. So, hey, as long
as these other powers are standing up, we're going to be okay
for a while longer.
I do think there's there's some element of that as well going
on here that would cause people to not believe
I don't know. Hard to know. I wish I wish I could trust any fact
coming out of this region like ever essentially. Like any testimony
coming out of this region. It's like every actor in the region
is just a known quantifiable
So, it sucks. crisis than Israel. Because remember Israel still
has nuclear weapons, and Israel is a very diverse, very sophisticated
economy, whereas Saudi Arabia is completely reliant on oil. And
it's always had problems with Iran because Iran is a theocracy
opposed to the Saudi monarchy.
Um Iran uh funds and equips
uh the Houthis, which have have been antagonistic towards Saudi
Arabia for the longest time.
And right now, the Saudi economy is suffering. Um it is it's
been trying to pivot towards more of a tourist economy. That's
why they brought in Ronaldo. That's why they're switching to
e-gaming.
Uh that's why they're being some building something called a
line, uh Neom. All these things are not working out. So, um they
need to be able to control
uh the oil resources of the Oh, Neom is apparently some the line
project, some futuristic [__] they were building.
MBS's city project. Okay. >> entire Middle East if they
are to survive and thrive as a nation. So, I do believe that
this uh re- reporting is credible, even though it does uh make
Saudi Arabia look bad. But, remember, Saudi Arabia says that
they wanted peace, but they are helping the Israelis and Americans
attack Iran right now because they're allowing the um Israelis
and Americans to use uh Saudi airspace. So, help us understand
because it still feels to me like there are some pieces that
don't totally add up. You had in advance of this war on Iran,
you had top military brass, up to the chairman of the Joint Chiefs
of Staff, saying, "This is a really bad idea. Um you know, we
are not ready for this." You know, all the the math on the interceptors
that's been talked about for for months at this point. And yet,
Trump still decided to go ahead. What is the calculus that he
was making here that led him to take what, you know, already
appears to be catastrophic actions? Right, okay. So, this is
the key question. Why did they do this? And I think there are
three possibilities, okay? And I think all three possibilities
are valid. The first is that it's hubris. If you look at history,
this is how empires behave. So, um the Madura kidnapping was
quick, successful, and it was adrenaline rush for Trump. And
that made him overconfident in the capacity of the American military.
Okay? So, hubris is a factor. We see this throughout history.
Why did Hitler invade Stalin? Because he conquered Europe really
easily, and he thought he was invincible, right? And that led
to
I don't think that's true. I think he knew that the Russian war
machine was spinning up, and that if he didn't get into Russia
before they had like everybody armed and fitted, that he was
going to be
I'm pretty confident that he did that preemptively cuz he knew
he was [__] if he didn't.
Okay. the destruction of the German army in uh the Soviet Union.
So, hubris is a factor. Then you have to look at internal political
calculus, where even though America does not benefit
from this [snorts] Did you read the New York Times article uh
going through some of the like lead-up to this?
Did you Did you get to like his number one general? The New York
Times article was talking about like their their whole They had
like eight different reporters on this, tons of sources. It was
talking about Bibi visiting the White House multiple times, convincing
Trump that war was the way. You've got to do war. You've got
to do war. But it discussed at one point when they were talking
with
Dean Cain, Dan Cain, whatever his name is, the general. Um basically,
Trump Trump talks to him.
Dan Cain says, "I Trying to achieve regime change in Iran? We'd
have to do a massive ground campaign. Like it would be crazy.
It would cost us a ton. It would cost us a ton of lives." And
Donald Trump basically came out after that and said, I I believe
he said something like regime change would be barely difficult.
It would be like a little more He's like, "We could easily strike
people, but regime change would be nothing." Right? He like came
out after that. Yeah, Raisin Cain. They came out after and Trump
basically said like, "Yeah, Dan Dan Cain told me it would be
very easy to change the regime there."
I have a feeling, I mean, Trump is literally demented, but also
he's saying that the Venezuela like deposing of Maduro is what
led Trump to have the hubris, and I think it's probably the strikes
as well, like the strikes from last year as well as this, if
that's what like where the psychology of Trump is at on this.
Yeah, yeah. I don't I think this hubris point is one of the more
salient things he said. Mhm. war against Iran. Trump himself
personally benefits. Why? Because the Saudis and Israelis are
bribing him to um attack Iran. Remember that the Saudi Yeah,
that's the other thing though is that like deposing Maduro is
not regime change. The guy who was immediately slotted in was
his VP. And yeah, it's Yeah. Definitely not regime change.
Leadership change, which I guess is what they're doing. They're
doing like soft regime change now. Leadership change to somebody
who doesn't want to die. Hey, do you not want to die? Okay, well,
then do what the US says. Oh, you don't want to do what we said?
Oh, well, sounds like you want to die.
Great way of to put new diplomacy strategy, guys, just dropped.
He's invested $2 billion in
>> be fun of Jared Kushner, who is the son-in-law of Donald
Trump, and Israelis former Adelson have been financing Trump's
political career. Right? So, um Miriam Adelson
a few months back said that she will um put up $250 million if
Trump were to run a third term. So, Trump is getting a lot of
financial and political support from the Saudis and Israelis.
Also, remember that if this war if this war goes sideways, and
Trump is forced to use ground troops, he will probably get approval
from
and this will give him emergency war powers, which will allow
him to
uh influence the midterms. So, Trump is thinking about a third
term. And I think at the ballot box, he probably won't get it,
but if there's a war going on and you can delay elections and
you have emergency war powers and people rally around the flag,
then he probably he probably will get a third term. And the last
Okay. This is like levels of authoritarianism that I don't put
put past Trump, but given his increasing like lack of political
viability as well and his age and falling popularity, I do think
Republicans, and I've thought this ever since they broke with
him on Epstein, are trying to think of what the party is going
like the future of the party is going to be beyond and I think
so many of them are just personally motivated to be the next
successor to the MAGA movement that they're not they're less
and he's just so old that they're less interested in like keeping
him around for like a third term.
The health thing's got to be huge. For Yeah. factor. >> Like
they are making moves to make it difficult to like they're not
going to steal an election. Like I do think it's going to be
like a free and fair election. I think what they're going to
attempt to do with these like save acts is make it as difficult
as possible to vote in the first place and that chilling effect
will may favor them. It's very important. It's an eschatological
factor where if you look at the Epstein files, it's clear that
we are run by secret societies. It's clear that the world is
run by these >> Bro, he I I was defending okay.
I was defending like this guy through like a couple of the claims
and now he just went from like Donald Trump >> at the end.
Yeah, Donald Trump's ending the democracy. He's running for a
third term with war powers and also the world's run by secret
societies. Okay, well. uh
>> who have a lot of power. We don't know who they are,
but they control the military, they control the national security
security apparatus. And these people we we they're different
names for these people. Uh you you can call them like Illuminati.
And they He just went He went all in. He went all in. And do
you think this is why it ends
This I maybe. Like, okay, thank you, Professor, for having for
coming on.
Thank you, sir. O7. Thank you, sir. Thank you.
It's like a reminder. This is just a random YouTuber who went
viral. This is not a guy who is actually well versed in foreign
policy, the history of the Middle East, Iran, the United States
military,
a ballistics expert, like nothing like that. Not an economist,
not not a historian, just just like a guy.
Dude, I wonder if he I wonder if a part of the grift is saying
a bunch of things that are like like reasonable to think or reasonable
to assume and then you like hit them with the Illuminati right
at the end and people are like, wait. He knew some other stuff.
Does he know Does he know about Does he know something? I I wonder
if that's a part of it, if he's like baking it in.
They're doing names for these people. You can call them like
Illuminati.
And the Illuminati are composed of three major groups, okay?
You have the Jesuits who control the Vatican. You have the Sabbatean
Frankists who which control the modern state of Israel today.
And you have the Freemasons.
Wait, who controls the modern state of Israel today? >> And
the Illuminati are composed of three major groups, okay? You
have the Jesuits who control the Vatican. You have the Sabbatean
Frankists who which control Sabbatean Frankists.
>> This is why Oh, no. The Sabbatean Frankists. Not the
Frankist stuff. Oh my god.
Oh, no. for the modern state He's lost. He's Candace Owens pilled.
He's actually I'm not joking. This is the Candace Owens bit.
Do you remember when she was talking about Frankists like a couple
like maybe two years ago? This is unironically a strategy like
a thing she's talked about a bunch. Is he Is he Is he gay pilled?
Is he NH pilled?
Let's just say that he's very suspicious of the tunnel tunnel
underneath that TPUSA pavilion, okay? They had a tunnel. Where
did Charlie go? Do we know where Charlie went? Possibly back
in time, forward in time, it's hard to say. Charlie is a man
out of time. >> which control the national security apparatus
of the United States. And they believe that Israel, this war
in the Middle East, is key to the end times, including heaven
on earth. So, it's almost like a script that they're following,
even though it's doesn't make any typical sense. protocols, you
might say. Like old man protocols? Something about old men in
the
of uh
of Zion.
Of the elders of Yeah. We are
I was I was hinting at it. Come on. >> reasons why this
is happening. I can't tell if you
There's an earnestness every now and
I hope he come back. This was very informative, I think, for
both of us. We deeply appreciate your time. Thank you. Thank
you. Hey, if you like that video, hit the like button.
After [laughter] like just ending on like the craziest note,
he's like, "Thanks for having me on." What are the comment section?
What is it
Hold on, I have to hear "Thanks for having me on." I just have
to hear it one more time. >> sense, okay? So, I would say
that these three are the best reasons why this is happening.
Wow. Well, sir, I hope you
No way! He's still doing "Well, sir" at the end. Back. This was
very informative, I think, for both of us. We deeply appreciate
your time. Thank you. I mean, I feel more informed on how insane
this guy is, so sure.
Sargon's crazy. I I would not Listen, I could I could give him
a plaque. >> idea by the end of this now. Like, I'm
Like, so I feel I feel like Sargon thinks this guy's got wisdom.
I'm sorry. I really do. I I feel like I would not be saying that
on the way out.
That's That's wild. If you ever just feel useless, remember it
took 2.5 trillion dollars in 20 years to replace the Taliban
with the Taliban.
Bro came, bro cooked, bro left. Remember the professor is not
Okay. Oh my god.
But I am. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. >> fears this guy.
Thank you. Thank you. YouTube commenters. Thank you.
By the way, people thought democracy could work. Just a reminder,
these people have the equal rights of representation that you
have, okay, in your governments. Awesome.
People are voting.
>> You definitely stood a chance. When the reporter asked
why we went to war, he was paid to. That's what I was saying,
shocked when the professor said it out
Bro, what score shirt there at the end, calling out the Illuminati.
Dude. 19,000 likes on that.
Yeah. Yeah, 19,000.
I love how you let him talk without interrupting him. Thank you
for being so
>> you I told you that that was only going to be viewed
as like a great thing to any of the like dark Professor Jiang
fanboys
to come in and see like, "Oh look, they didn't try to like challenge
him on anything. These people aren't in the the sunken place.
They're basing
Dude, it's like actually all of the Candace Owens fans and the
dude, it's all the Candace Owens fans. It's all the
How do you How do you stave off the black pill with stuff like
this? What's up, Queen? How's it going?
How do you stave off the black pill? By the way, we're on Twitch
right now, just so you
Oh, wait. When Are we not on Twitch
No, we're not. Well, I'm on Twitch, so yeah, we are. Oh, yeah,
we're fine. Okay, okay. Yeah.
Yeah. Have you been watching any of this? It's kind of wild.
I watched a little bit earlier, but then I I I didn't have Damn,
he missed the show. Show him the ending. Show him the ending.
Just the last minute. Wait. Have you seen this Professor Jean
guy before? You know who this guy is roughly? I've heard that
name. I've heard that name. It's the predictive history guy.
He's like dangerous. >> who went viral for like predicting
that Trump would win Trump would win the 2024 election, start
a war with Iran, and then lose. Yeah. So >> Why why have
I heard this guy's name before? What what is he Collapse of the
He's loved and hated. Yes.
Uh you'll you'll see. Just we'll watch this thing. You can see
it'll be clear. >> do I have my shirt?
Okay, here we go.
Okay, last minute or so. I'll I might move this back a little
bit more if you need slightly more context, but >> going
on, and you can delay your
the midterms. So, Trump is thinking about a third term. And I
think at the ballot box, he probably won't get it. But if there's
a war going on, and you can delay elections, and you have emergency
war powers, and people rally on the flag, then he probably he
probably will get a third term.
I think you just clicked in, but it's fine. This guy's talking
about Trump running for a third term, okay?
And the last factor that is very important is a eschatological
factor. Where, if you look at the Epstein files, it's clear that
we are run by secret societies. It's clear that the world is
run by these uh individuals who have a lot of power. We don't
know who they are, but they control the military, they control
the national security security apparatus. And these people we
would we they're different names for these people. Uh you can
call them like Illuminati.
And Illuminati are composed of three major
March 2nd, 5 million views.
5 million views. And this guy doesn't even have a PhD in anything.
He's not. He doesn't. But he's not done yet. He's actually not
done. You thought Illuminati was just just >> you have
the you have the Jesuits who control the Vatican. You have the
Sabbatean Frankists who which control the modern state of Israel
today.
The Frankists are back. Okay. The Jesuits, I believe that's the
Zohar conspiracy, the the black pope, all of this. Okay. This
guy's going off. You have the Freemasons which control the national
security apparatus of the United States. And they believe
This guy's a Zohar viewer. Unironic. This guy's also a Zohar
men transfer knowledge to each other. Ask this guy how men get
get so smart in
that Israel, this war in the Middle East, is key to the end times,
including heaven on earth. So, it's almost like a script that
they're following even though it's doesn't make any typical sense.
Okay. So, I would say that these three are the best reasons why
this is happening. Wow. Well, sir, I hope you come back. This
was very informative, I think, for both of us. We deeply appreciate
your time. Thank you. >> god. Thank you. I lost it in Zohar
at the end there, dude. Oh my [laughter] goodness. Crystal didn't
say a word. So, we were just reading the comments when you came
in. Oh, and scorched scorched earth at the end there, calling
out the Illuminati.
I love how you let him talk without interrupting him. Thank you
for being so
Very very called this a How do people still say the Illuminati?
Like I don't even know how you bring yourself to like
you're talking about the Illuminati in the in 2016. Too complex,
man. When shit's just so much Yeah. I know, but it's just so
much [__] less, like
This guy's literally an astrologer he's an astrologist.
>> That's it.
It's just manifesting and wish casting.
Yep. It's um Yeah. And also like he's trying to
if this is like a grift or whatever and he realizes, oh wow,
people are paying a lot of like putting a lot of stock and attention
and like the things that I say. If he really wants to make money,
like saying [__] like that will attract you people
that think that you have like secret knowledge and are willing
to pay you a bunch of money.
It's the same way that like Andrew Tate when he says insane things,
like he gets attention, but it self-selects for the stupidest
people because only the stupidest people would actually take
him seriously and think that he has something insightful to say
or offer you and you need to give him a bunch of money on Patreon
every month for secret knowledge that he possesses. Like I feel
like if this guy has like two brain cells to rub together, he
probably saw the response and was like, oh, I attracted this
audience. Well, this audience is like the easiest audience in
the world to like get their money.
And if you just started saying [__] like this, it
will come in.